thierry mariani vous êtes député même
plus beaucoup vous aviez déjà rencontré
dans une affaire dont les gars se fait
ailleurs
écoutez je vous ai je vous ai écouté
attentivement depuis des lunes demi
heure je crois vous présenter
effectivement une image renouvelée plus
fraîches c'est le sens vous propos il ya
quelques minutes du front national mais
mais je cherche un peu le changement de
discours je cherche un peu le singe le
changement de discours parce que je
crois qu'aujourd'hui la situation a
complètement changé depuis six mois
la cohabitation est fini il y à nouveau
gouvernement qui met en place une
politique radicalement différente de la
politique précédente
et vous me permettrez de dire deux
choses c'est que aujourd'hui les
préoccupations des français à mon avis
son premier rang
j'apprends des quatre exemples très
brièvement en matière de sécurité en
matière de sécurité je crois qu'avec les
projets de loi présenté par nicolas
sarkozy il y a quelques mois et d'autre
part dans quelques semaines et bien
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit ce
sont des problèmes très concrets je veux
dire quand on parle des poèmes de
prostitution des problèmes d'euros
d'immeubles quand on parle de problèmes
de gens du voyage ou d'autres problèmes
ce sont des problèmes qui parle dans
n'était pas réglée par la loi
excusez moi je prends un exemple de gens
du voyage qui est un jour d'hui car le
ministre dit s'il ya des problèmes
avérés on peut envisager la saisie du
véhicule
la loi actuelle ne permet pas vous
regretterez claquant même c'est une
avancée intéressante qui est proposée
par la loi donc en matière de sécurité
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya une réelle
avancée fait par ce gouvernement avec
une voie équilibrée qui me antigènes ne
tue je vous rejoins les jeux ne sont pas
tous des délinquants loin de là mais il
ya une partie effectivement il faut
réprimer et aussi et je le dis tout de
suite une loi qui est ni anti pauvres
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un peuvent
aujourd'hui comme nicolas sarkozy le
dixième peuvent ces quelques cas
personne pour le protéger et le son seul
recours sont seuls remparts c'est la loi
elle c'est l'état et au contraire quand
les voitures brûlent à strasbourg et
bien c'est plus souvent les pauvres qui
sont touchés que les gens qui ont des
moyens
un gouvernement qui a changer
complètement sa politique en matière de
sécurité
sarkozy c'est payant un gouvernement qui
a changer complètement sa politique en
matière de justice
je vous suis tout à fait pour être un
mini terrain sur l'épreuve justice à
carpentras 22 nuls à faire l'année
dernière pour trois magistrats du
parquet 5% du budget de l'état sont
donnés à la justice
si on ne donne pas une vraie priorité la
justice ça sert à rien de voter des lois
sur la sécurité
et je trouve que justement ce
gouvernement d
avec les lois votées ce à l'initiative
de dominique perben a pris le problème à
bras le corps pour former de nouveaux
magistrats et faire en sorte que cette
justice rachel mieux c'est marine le pen
a presté parce que là et puis je suis
allé
alors je laisse la marine le pen avec
plaisir répondre sur ces deux points
ramenés de monsieur main et non à la
question je pensais que ce que vous
faites à l'ump je suis très bien même
très bien parce que vous êtes tout le
mond proches quels que soient les
domaines d'ailleurs des options du front
national que parfois je me demande ce
que vous avez en commun avec monsieur
jego et monsieur douste-blazy donc ne
pouvait tout de même pas ignorer
l'existence et quand j'entends votre
avis et jacques bompard rome j'ai
l'impression d'être un gauchiste complet
de tyria départ mais également proche de
nous que vous apporte un petit but à 2
c'est très gentil mais je vous laisse
volontiers vous laisse les mairesses
volontiers
[Musique]